il suffit parfois d'un court moment pour
que dans une vie tout bascule c'est ce
qui s'est passé pour Judicaël Hirel
notre confrère du Figaro Magazine
agressé dans un couloir de métro alors
qu'il tentait de porter secours à une
jeune femme regarde
bonjour Judica lirel bonjour vous êtes
journaliste au Figaro c'est des images
de vous d'ailleurs qu'on convoyait juste
à l'instant sur l'écran
vous êtes l'auteur de ce livre que j'ai
dans les mains et qu'on va montrer à
l'écran ça s'appelle concours de rouge
dans la peau d'une victime d'agression
et c'est parue aux éditions du
Cherche-Midi
vous commencez dans ce livre par
raconter ce qui vous est arrivé c'était
un 13 novembre un 13 novembre 2017 un
autre 13 novembre vous dites dans votre
livre qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ce soir
là rentrée du bureau tout simplement
donc c'est quelque chose que tout le
monde fait tous les jours quelques
millions de personnes auront du bureau
tous les jours en pourront les
transports en commun et en l'occurrence
quand on à Paris on prend généralement
le métro quand on traverse Paris dans un
sens et dans l'autre deux fois par jour
donc ça peut c'est quelque chose qui
d'une banalité totale je prenais le
métro mais correspondance à Paris on est
toujours un petit peu stressé un peu
speed il faut toujours courir donc du
coup je me mettais dans la première
voiture pour avoir moins de distance sur
le quai pour gagner 2 minutes pour la
correspondance parce que on est un petit
peu stressé quand même et en sortant de
du métro à la station Concorde station
concorde entre les lignes Balard et
châteaux de Vincennes une grande
correspondance au centre de Paris
finalement je descends du métro devant
moi dans la première âme il y avait un
homme que j'avais déjà vu dans la rame
qui était pas très très frais avec sa
bouteille de bière à la main qui se
parlait tout seul alors qu'il y avait
pas les foule et une autre jeune femme
qui montait devant les trois premiers à
descendre de la RAM de métro et à monter
ce grand escalier pour aller prendre
telle ou tel correspondance et puis là
je vois cet homme juste derrière la
jeune femme regardez ostensiblement ses
fesses il faut être clair vraiment
lourdement ça on voyait bien que ce qui
regardait ce n'était pas l'escalier et
mettre une grande main aux fesses à
cette jeune femme qui n'avait rien
demandé qui rentrait un bureau elle
aussi donc évidemment moi je vois ça
juste derrière elle ses écouteurs elle
se met protester lui encore plus stupide
dire qu'il a rien fait et commencer à
s'en prendre un petit peu à elle juste
dans un angle du couloir donc ça pouvait
très mal se passer très très vite parce
que franchement quelqu'un qui agresse
comme ça qui a une grande bouteille
d'alcool à la main franchement s'il y a
assez peu de chance que ça finisse bien
et vous êtes intervenus à ce moment donc
je suis préfère intervenir à ce moment
je vais pas attendre qu'elle se fasse
frapper parce que j'ai l'impression que
ça allait se passer comme ça il valait
mieux juste avoir intervenir et donc je
suis allé voir cette demoiselle si ça
allait j'ai dit directement ce type qui
savent très bien ce qu'il avait fait
qu'on en est ce qu'on allait en rester
là et je suis parti avec la jeune femme
un petit peu calmement en l'exfiltrant
en refusant de me battre avec lui parce
que lui tout de suite poser sa bouteille
de tuyaux de bas tu veux te battre parce
que c'était quelqu'un qui était pas très
en forme dans sa tête on va dire ou
drogué en plus des prises en tout cas
agressif donc je faisais me battre je
suis parti avec elle et puis voilà pour
moi c'était à faire classer après il y a
un long long couloir tout droit qui
traverse l'ensemble console de la place
de la Concorde vraiment interminable je
gère pas très régulièrement et j'ai
pensé que c'était fini et j'allais
donner ma carte de visite à cette jeune
femme pour lui laisser mes coordonnées
pour qu'elles éventuellement un porte
plainte ce qui me paraissait assez
logique et ce que je ne savais pas et je
l'ai appris par la suite c'est que ce
type c'était dissimulé dans un des
couloirs latéraux de du métro à mis ses
capuche il était revenu derrière moi et
donc il arrivait derrière moi en sautant
il y a un grand coup de poing dans
l'attente sur le côté de la tête avec sa
bouteille et son point donc il m'a mis
KO directement il m'a explosé la tempe
au sens propre donc après je me rappelle
de rien j'ai juste eu ce changement
rappelle c'est d'avoir vu rouge et
d'avoir vu noir comme dans un jeu vidéo
et l'écran s'éteint avec Game Over alors
concrètement le votre agresseur a
continué à ce moment-là à s'acharner sur
vous on a explosé la tête à coup de pied
la jeune femme est également intervenue
pour éviter finalement qui vous prenne
la vie c'est jeté sur moi de façon à me
protéger c'est pris des coups dans le
dos et des coups de pieds et aussi en
appelant au secours évidemment personne
intervenue mais en revanche le fait
qu'il y ait créé qui me protège évitez
je prenne un petit coup de pied en plus
parce qu'on serait pas là pour en parler
et a permis de mettre en fuite parce que
du coup il a réalisé quelque chose et il
est parti en courant alors après tout de
même vous avez repris conscience
quelques minutes plus tard sur le moment
vous n'avez vous le racontez dans votre
livre vous n'avez pas du tout conscience
la gravité de votre agression vous
arrivez à l'hôpital vous êtes
effectivement bien embauché mais vous
continuez à noter tout ce qui se passe
autour de vous oui si vous êtes un
réflexe journalistique une distanciation
philosophique à l'objet on vit quelque
chose et en même temps on l'observe donc
c'est assez paradoxal il y a
dédoublement de personnalité et puis
c'est quand même pas très réaliste tout
ça j'étais un peu chaos j'étais pas très
en forme mais je pense que ça vaut
inconsciemment continue à fonctionner il
y a tout enregistré en mode automatique
vous avez gardé des séquelles de votre
agression j'ai dit qu'elle irait oui oui
quand même la partie gauche du visage
mais si tout était bien fait puisqu'on a
on a mis sous ma peau en fait une petite
plaque de métal qui permettent de tenir
les os en place donc ils se sont
ressoudé depuis donc ça va très bien
mais mon crâne n'a jamais été aussi
solide mais à l'époque il fallait le
faire tenir en place pour pour éviter
que ça retombe par la suite mais entre
les photos de donc du coup toute la
partie gauche du visage aussi entre
n'importe quoi et rien du tout donc
entre le fait de pas avoir de sensations
comme pour l'élève ou pour le côté du
nez ou le fait de lancer pour les autres
parties parce que dernière envoie des
mauvais messages donc c'est c'est
injuste milieu entre rage de dents et
gueule de bois permanente
je dis Carelle votre agresseur il n'a
jamais été retrouvé jamais il court
toujours jamais jamais il a il s'est
enfui en courant quelques hommes ont
cherché à l'attraper mais ils lui ont
échapper et lui échappé et après on l'a
jamais revu et il n'a jamais été
retrouvé il était assez peu cherché pour
être sincère ma plainte a été classée
très rapidement je suis passé à la
police pour chercher l'identifier dans
les dans les fichiers parce qu'on
regarde vous savez comment les séries
télé sur un écran toutes les photos j'ai
reconnu personne donc à partir de là
c'est plein de contrix merci au revoir
c'est mon seul regret de cette histoire
pour être sincère c'est que c'est Tom
qui est dangereux foncièrement dangereux
puisqu'en quelques minutes il agressé
une femme puis moi-même et ton liberté
je me suis toujours demandé ce qu'il
avait pu faire de pire ou d'autres
depuis
vous parler aussi dans votre livre de la
RATP vous n'avez jamais alors ça paraît
complètement dingue vous n'avez jamais
été recontacté depuis votre agression
par les services de RATP vous les avez
contactés vous n'avez jamais eu de
retour j'ai contacté après plus
récemment j'ai contacté un service
communication pour savoir pourquoi en
tant que usager j'avais jamais eu de
retour j'attends toujours la réponse
aussi sur ce point-là mais c'est vrai
que quand je me suis réveillé dans ce
couloir de métro il y a des gens qui
sont occupés de moi qui ont été
adorables évidemment il y a très vite
deux agents RATP qui sont arrivés puis
deux je policiers puis deux pompiers
tout va par deux bizarrement je sais pas
pourquoi mais les deux agents de RATP je
me rappelle très bien parce que j'étais
quand même bien sonné quand on sort d'un
chaos comme ça on n'est pas vraiment en
forme me demandez mon nom et mon numéro
de téléphone puisque j'ai réussi à
donner finalement et je ne sais toujours
pas pourquoi au bout de cinq ans parce
que je n'ai jamais eu un coup de fil
pour me demander comment ça allait pour
m'orienter vers une association des
devises vers un psychologue quelque
chose et en discutant autour de moi
parce que beaucoup de gens sont dû me
raconter leur propre agression depuis
ces gens de choses qui vivaient la
parole je ne connais pas une personne
qui était recontactée par RATP après
cette fête donc à quoi bon prendre nos
coordonnées je ne sais pas alors pareil
vous vous expliquez votre
incompréhension on est dans le métro a
priori il y a des caméras de
surveillance dans le métro sauf que ces
images pareil elles n'ont jamais pu les
exploiter heureusement était très
brièvement exploité mais franchement
prenez votre smartphone comme vous
assistez à une agression prenez une
photo une petite vidéo ça sera 10000
fois meilleur que ce que j'ai pu voir
comme extraction de la bande vidéo de la
caméra parce que les caméras sont sans
doute à toute récentes elles sont
protégées par une vitre assez épaisse et
son général placées sur un point où donc
là en l'occurrence que j'ai vu mon
agresseur c'est le mauvaise image floue
de quelqu'un portant une capuche je vous
défie quiconque de reconnaître qui que
ce soit mais en plus le pire c'est que
c'est quand même ces images de toute
façon ne sont pas conservées ça rappelle
un petit peu les Anglais du Stade de
France d'une affaire plus récente mais
quand je me suis renseigné la finale de
la Ligue des Champions moi j'ai porté
plainte étant juriste de formation le
lendemain mon agression je suis allé
avec mes factures au visage dans un
commissariat porter plainte parce que je
savais que ça permettait de conserver
toute preuve
utile donc ça je l'ai fait en vain mais
que j'ai fait quand même mais quand j'ai
contacté la RATP sur la question de
vidéo on m'a appris deux versions
différentes une première version on m'a
dit que pour des raisons de protection
de la vie privée et de CNIL on ne
pouvait pas garder les vidéos plus 48
heures et une autre fois de m'a répondu
qu'on avait pas les capacités de
stockage pour garder les images je ne
sais pas quelle est la vraie version ce
qui est sûr en tout cas c'est que
au-delà de quelques jours les images
sont détruites et ça c'est quand même
assez dingue parce que finalement ça
serait très simple et c'est un des un
des buts de ce livre que je que j'ai
écrit ça serait très simple de décider
qu'une régie de transport qu'elle soit
parisienne ou autre quand elle constate
une agression dans ses locaux dans ces
murs garde par anticipation les images
vidéos à disposition de la justice si
plus tard la victime porte plainte alors
que là il faut que je porte plainte que
la police réquisitionnent les images et
après elles sont conservées c'est ce que
nous dit Christian Léon sur Le Figaro.fr
le métro parisien investit des milliers
de caméras à des milliers d'euros dans
des caméras de surveillance mais qui
visiblement ne servent à rien c'est un
petit peu le constat que que vous vous
avez fait alors dans votre livre judical
IRL vous tentez de prendre de la hauteur
aussi
vous revenez sur l'idée de sentiment
d'insécurité alors ce n'est pas un
sentiment qui a fait de moi une gueule
cassé c'est ce que vous dites vous
reprenez les chiffres 2000 agression par
jour ce sont des chiffres de l'INSEE du
premier semestre 2021 ces chiffres elles
sont énormes il y a votre agression
aussi qui témoigne de la violence qu'on
peut vivre au quotidien dans dans les
transports en général en France pourtant
on a l'impression que tout le monde
regarde d'ailleurs c'est très paradoxal
effectivement parce que c'est une sorte
de violence à bas bruit d'insécurité à
bas bruit on a un petit peu mis ça sous
la sous la moquette j'ai l'impression si
on se concentre uniquement sur les
agressions dans les transports en commun
c'est celle pour lesquelles je me
passionne pour des raisons évidentes
c'est en gros 130140 000 plaintes par an
pour des vols des volailles violence des
agressions des agressions sexuelles sur
l'ensemble du territoire français qui
ont moyen de représentent quand même 350
personnes par jour c'est comme si un
avion de ligne un Airbus se faisait
agresser chaque jour sauf que ce n'est
pas un Airbus c'est une personne une
personne et ça ce sont les plaintes qui
sont déposées Vous dites aussi que toute
une série de plaintes sont probablement
même pas déposées et donc complètement
invisible je découvrais encore rien de
statistique sur le fait que pour les
agressions sexuelles hors du contexte
familial il y a à peu près 10% des
personnes qui portent plainte or là on
voit déjà que dans les transports en
commun il y a une progression constante
des agressions asexuelles contre les
femmes qui évidemment c'est 94% des
victimes féminines Nancy et que dans ces
femmes qui sont en première ligne de la
sécurité de transport en commun qui ont
vraiment peur de prendre les transports
au quotidien il y a de plus en plus de
jeunes femmes à être agressées moins de
25 ans et même de plus en plus de
mineurs 40% sont des mineurs donc est-ce
que c'est vraiment une bonne expérience
pour commencer sa vie dans la cité que
de penser que l'on va se faire agresser
par un prédateur ou un malade dans les
transports ça ça me paraît strictement
inacceptable en 2023 et c'est vraiment
la colère principale qui a porté la
rédaction de ce livre je suis peut-être
trop féministe ou respectueux des femmes
je sais pas mais je ne comprends pas
qu'on se contente d'accepter que ça
puisse exister que au quotidien dans la
charge mentale le bal des femmes comme
on l'appelle aujourd'hui il y a cette
couche sur je dois faire attention à ne
pas me faire agresser c'est marquant
vous vous racontez que depuis que vous
avez depuis que vous tém de votre
histoire vous avez énormément de femmes
dans votre entourage familial mais pas
que qui viennent vous parler qui vous
disent qui vous racontent les agressions
qu'elles ont vécu depuis des années vous
dites je me rendais pas compte que
c'était à ce point-là mais j'étais en
colère contre moi-même à 45 ans je
m'étais jamais rendu compte que dans les
transports en commun les femmes avaient
peur de prendre les transports parce que
moi effectivement je fais mes 80 j'ai
une formation officier je j'ai fait les
arts martiaux je suis calme de nature
j'ai jamais ressenti cette crainte et je
l'ai toujours pas d'ailleurs en revanche
une femme va devoir y penser d'emblée
une étudiante qui s'installe sur Paris
devra réfléchir ou est-ce qu'il
s'installe pour que la ligne métro soit
sur pour se rendre à sa faculté une
femme va faire attention à ne pas mettre
de talons pour pas faire clac dans les
couleurs pour pas attirer l'attention
une autre va baisser les yeux beaucoup
d'autres me disent qu'elles prennent
tout simplement pas le métro elles vont
prendre la voiture elles vont prendre le
vélo mais vont éviter de mettre une
enquête qui est sortie de la région
parisienne qui dit que 5% des femmes ont
renoncé à prendre les transports en
commun par peur de se faire agresser
déjà énorme vous avez rencontré un haut
gradé un policier
il vous a dit une phrase qui vous a mis
hors de vous c'est ce que vous racontez
dans votre livre et vous a dit
d'habitude personne n'intervient jamais
dans ce genre de situation cette phrase
elle vous a mis énormément en colère
pour quelles raisons c'est vrai que
c'est un consentait de colère solide
finalement que ça fait du bien d'écrire
aussi pour être un peu moins en colère
mais c'était préfet de police du
Val-de-Marne parce que la mère de ma
ville a eu la gentillesse de proposer
comme on met une médaille en disant que
j'étais un héros parce que je considère
pas d'ailleurs toujours pas j'ai fait ce
que j'avais à faire à un moment précis
et j'en ferai exactement la même chose
et ça me paraît pas négociable mais je
ne me vis pas comme un héros les héros
c'est des policiers les gendarmes les
gens qui mettent tous les jours leur vie
en danger on l'a encore vu avec des
policiers dans l'ordre ces derniers
jours mais en fait ça m'a mis en colère
de d'être considéré comme un héros parce
que j'étais le seul à faire ce qu'il
devrait être fait par tout le monde
c'est-à-dire intervenir quand on voit
une personne et notamment une femme se
faire agresser pour moi c'est normal
c'est ça tombe sous le sens c'est pas
négociable et là un préfet de police me
dit
on vous décore parce que vous êtes un
des seuls à intervenir jamais personne
n'intervient et c'est vrai que lors de
la remise ces décorations qu'elle a la
médaille pour avoir du courage et
dévouement à laquelle je tiens beaucoup
parce que je sais à quel point policier
gendarme aux pompiers tiennent à l'avoir
et les conditions dans lesquelles on
était deux civils parmi des dizaines de
policiers à décorer tous les deux pour
être intervenus sur une agression sur
une femme et là on se dit oui
effectivement il y a quand même un
problème certes on peut se faire blesser
ça m'est arrivé une fois sur X fois où
je mets le poliment de ce qui peut se
passer autour de moi parce que j'ai
jamais cherché la bagarre c'est pas mon
si je ne le ferai pas mais ça c'est un
risque qui vaut le coup d'être pris je
pense c'est pas négociable c'est une
règle de vivre ensemble à mes yeux et la
partie à chacun de penser à tous je
commence à accepter que la peur prenne
le dessus se dire je suis trop pressé je
vais pas regarder on sait jamais
l'agresseur a déjà gagné avant
d'agresser finalement c'est quand même
dommage et en même temps j'ai dit
qu'elle est IRL vous vous décrivez bien
à quel point une fois que vous avez été
agressé personne n'a répondu on parlait
de la RATP tout à l'heure mais ça a mis
trois ans pour que vous puissiez avoir
une expertise judiciaire de ce qui vous
était arrivé
vous dites que dans votre livre que un
des risques c'est de voir à force les
citoyens vouloir se faire justice
eux-mêmes j'ai un peu peur de ça
effectivement j'ai l'impression et on le
voit qu'on commence à apparaître dans
certains faits divers au quotidien que à
partir du moment où on se dit que on va
pas être assez défendu qui a de plus en
plus agresseurs que la justice ne va pas
automatiquement les mettre en prison ou
autre tout ça s'additionne finalement
des gens vont être tentés d'être armés
d'avoir une bombe sur eux d'avoir un
couteau de faire une justice punitive
dans le régler leur compte même et là on
sort des limites d'une société civilisée
vous revenez aussi dans votre livre dans
l'un des chapitres sur la condition de
victime alors vous dites il faut faire
avec et en même temps vous même vous
vous refusez de vous considérer comme
une victime pour quelle raison
je pense que je suis un horrible têtu
breton et que je n'accepte pas de subir
quelque chose que j'ai pas choisi donc
je j'ai pas choisi d'être une victime ça
m'est tombé dessus même si contrairement
à la plupart des victimes je sais
pourquoi ça m'est arrivé ce qui m'évite
de gamberger trop j'étais pas là où les
endroits au même moment quand on se fait
agresser qu'on a rien demandé à personne
vraiment c'est injuste moi je sais je me
dis j'ai été agressé en défendant
quelqu'un donc du coup sur ça je suis
apaisé mais en revanche c'est vrai que
j'ai pas choisi d'être une victime j'ai
pas choisi de le rester mais pourtant je
vais le rester à vitam donc je déteste
subir les choses j'ai mis à garder une
certaine marge de choix je pense comme
tout le monde j'ai dit qu'elle est elle
vous avait repris alors je ne suis pas
un grand secret même si c'est dans votre
livre mais sans aller dans le détail
bien sûr pour ceux qui le découvriraient
plus tard mais vous avez repris contact
avec la jeune femme que vous avez
défendu dans le métro
vous avez pu échanger après sur ce qui
vous était arrivé vous vous étiez pas
parlé dans l'intervalle non bon le covid
était passé par l'iPhone dire la
pandémie un petit peu mais tout le monde
a l'écart de tout le monde pendant un
bon moment donc déjà ça relativise de
temps qu'on a mis à se croiser mais
bêtement quand j'ai été agressé elle
avait voulu m'accompagner aux urgences
et ça lui a été interdit et on n'a pas
voulu donner ses coordonnées parce qu'il
n'était pas de la famille et que vous
laissez constance on les a que je
risquais de lui en vouloir donc j'ai
appris ça en discutant avec elle c'était
une des choses que je voulais savoir et
j'ai regretter beaucoup finalement ce
temps perdu et qu'on les passe un peu
moins accompagner parce qu'on avait un
lien particulier à ce sujet mais je
tenais à la revoir pour être sûr
qu'elles ne s'en voulait pas de ce qui
m'est arrivé parce que moi je lui en
veux pas du tout c'est pourquoi est-ce
qu'on en voudrait une victime c'est les
agresseurs les coupables et le vrai
souci c'est que souvent les les victimes
d'agression se sentent coupables c'est
cette fête agresser donc je voulais
savoir si le vivait bien elle m'a quand
même vu me faire quasiment tuer à côté
d'elle c'est pas un spectacle très
agréable sincèrement moi ça va je me
rappelle pas j'étais ko je me rappelle
de rien et j'étais ravi de la revoir et
j'ai été ravi d'apprendre à cette
occasion là et un peu triste aussi que
finalement c'est elle qui m'a sauvé la
vie et pas l'inverse parce que si elle
m'avait pas protégé les un ou deux coups
de pied en plus que j'aurais eu dans la
tête aurait suffi à me tuer
le nombre d'agressions dans les
transports en commun je dis qu'elle il
reste très important pas qu'à Paris
d'ailleurs pas trop tôt partout en
France vous le rappelez dans votre livre
c'est pas une spéciste une spécificité
parisienne à votre avis pourquoi parce
que ce n'est pas le cas dans tous les
pays d'Europe j'ai l'impression que les
c'est assez dur de comparer les
conditions de sécurité dans les pays
d'Europe dans les transports en commun
mais que en France on a quand même une
petite particularité là-dessus j'ai
l'impression qu'en France les chiffres
sont plus élevés mais en même temps
quand on regarde le nombre de voyageurs
ça reste dans l'épaisseur du trait nous
ne sommes nous victimes d'agression que
les statistiques acceptables c'est pas
grave finalement par rapport au millions
et millions de voyageurs qui a si
quelques-uns se font tuer agresser
violer dépouillés dans les transports
on prend ça avec un regard je pense
froidement statistique c'est-à-dire
qu'on ne voit pas des gens on ne voit
pas une personne dans la vie va changer
du tout tout qui me pourra peut-être
plus jamais travailler qui veut garder
ici que la psychologiques dont les
proches aussi vont être atteints parce
que tout le col dommage que latéral de
la famille et des amis ou des collègues
qui portent aussi ça avec soi et je
pense qu'on le voit comme des
statistiques notamment d'un point de vue
politique
c'est mieux de déshumaniser les choses
et un chiffre positif faut dire regarder
finalement sur X voyageurs il y a 0,01%
de personnes qui se font agressées c'est
acceptable simplement
[Musique]